I've decided to go back to being a man, Irish
.
What a man, if the
prince were alive he would have said something like this
Thank you for helping me
Hey, both of us
won't go to a place where we can see better From tomorrow
Monnoji goodbye and thank you The parade
will begin Today is the eve of the festival
[music]
I'm sorry I worried you about what I should do when
I heard that you died safely. Did you call me? Are
you going home?  Do you want to go back to town with me?
[Music]
I won't be alone, right?
Hey, what's going on?
Your true nature is different from what I thought
, so why are you
talking
like that?
yo
[music]
I'm sorry for saying such terrible things.
I want you to stay in the castle forever.